the best compliment I got from these
were it just felt normal like no one
really had a question it moves exactly
like a real Mouse yeah it skips and hops
and little beats and rhythms I got the
option to do
this Fiona what a statement yeah I did a
little bit of some Yoda the outside and
the inside of the worm's mouth is based
on a throat of a beat boxer
[Laughter]
thanks to Bessie for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end so you can
find out how to get 25 off of each pair
of bessies
hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artists react
today is a very special day because we
are joined by none other than Robin
luckum from d-neck he is the global head
of Animation think of the Earth with a
face on and that's what he is
Robin can you tell us a little bit about
what you do yeah it's interesting I'm a
animation director for VFX animation as
opposed to feature animations when
people think of animated films another
thing another toy stories bugs lives so
for animation for VFX you're talking
like animating creatures like machines
anything that moves yes he would say
things like all the work done on say
Avengers that's more VFX animation so
again sound Awesomes that technicality
they have creatures in them but they
don't perform kind of in that Disney
style where it's very orchestrated kind
of movement it's not really kind of
telegraph movements So It's Tricky um
because there's two different
disciplines and when you say your
animation they're like oh cool how's
Mickey Mouse I'm like never met him but
it's both brilliant respected fields
that I've just done that photo on Dune
were you responsible for overseeing the
animation of the ornithopter Wings
that's so good that is it is amazing
that motion blur on the yeah
yes I guess
should we jump in on the order
thanks again man this is the first time
the same shot
there's his wings I love that you guys
made him look like actual dragonflies
I'm a big fan of dragonflies in general
they're the only creature that can
actually do like 3D flight like Ford
back up down left right like no other
creature can do that yeah when we were
given like the task it's not laid out
like make a dragonfly and I didn't
really want that one like okay this is a
mechanical object how does this actually
fly and so we're working out okay you
know a giant Albatross like giant Wings
it's creating down for us to lift it up
but the wings are so thin we had to make
them faster and faster this just didn't
look right we were trying all these
mechanical ways so you're following the
actual physical rule the smaller the
wing the faster it has to move yeah and
it's the wind was just thin so we kind
of looked at different ideas we did like
I liked laputa and they have these kind
of little dragonfly things and we looked
at loads of old kind of helicopter
footage of you know people trying to
take off like the Wright brothers but
then we had to work out okay well
there's eight of these and if they
started to flare apart they look quite
thin and just didn't look like it would
keep it in the air so okay okay make
sure the animes kept them closer
together and then we started during The
Buzz
now we worked on so many different
methods to try and work out this buzz
and we I think we're doing 11 subframes
per frame really okay that's what I was
curious about because obviously it's
vibrating more than there are frames
yeah yeah and so like how many times is
it going up and down per frame so you're
saying it's 11 times it's also about the
level of blur within the blur yeah so
you need to see the rhythm of the blades
within that blur to decide is it going
left or right so when it flares up more
blur in there looks like it's going that
way interesting I need to kind of change
the Rhythm the speed so when we're
driving it as an animator we're
increasing on that side it goes that way
okay it's like capitalizing on the idea
that like subconsciously we understand
that the more blur the faster the motion
is happening yes exactly and you can
then realize that it could be motivated
for turning it in yeah so that's the
laws we created and the best I got from
these were it just felt normal like no
one really had a question yeah this
feels real this is yeah I was like this
is nuts
so you also worked on animating the worm
here too right but yes we did the worm
even it was in a few shots we had to do
it in a way it was biologically accurate
to start unlike normal I would go right
into my biology and started researching
every type of worm we have tests of It
kind of doing a concertina like an
earthworm and like we're like oh maybe
it has bristles that stick out and under
the sand it pushes itself around with
bristles so how does it motivate itself
I dive so deep into that mechanics it
just wasn't working it was too organic
and it felt like a creature but it
wasn't this sand worm God so we took a
Mac reviewed and if you see the worm in
the environment of all the sand the sand
starts to become vast oceans almost and
the worm starts to move through those
oceans and the sand particles compared
to the size of them it's almost like
it's water interesting wait so because
of the scale of the worm you're actually
getting like fluid dynamics yeah so the
the effects renders were actually coming
out fluid we started to look at this
kind of concept of it being a bit more
Godlike and having a bit more Elegance
so then it started to move up and down
through the Contour tours and it had
this like whale kind of feel
because it has this vibration it has the
liquefaction of this yeah liquefaction
exactly that is kind of shows how it's a
bit of a master of the stand as well the
outside and the inside of the worm's
mouth is based on a throat of a
beatboxer
and liquefying the sand so we found this
really uncomfortable footage of a camera
and to the throat of a beatboxer that
footage is disgusting
I showed it to Paul he's like this is
disgusting but I can see how amazing it
could be it has a nice like contrast
because I wanted to work out how the
muscles could work inside the worm that
could produce sound or anything so all
the muscles inside the mouth which you
can't really see actually they're driven
and they move and they articulate all
those muscles are not just animating for
the sake they're actually based on how
would that noise come out what muscles
would move to me yeah that is
fascinating for one shot
in the dark yeah
still it reads I mean this is the first
moment there's a face to face with the
worm I think whether you're pulling a
detail like that or some other detail I
think there always has to be some detail
in that regard something that's thought
out something that's established in the
world that just makes it a little bit
richer for I think these shots to really
have the impact they need to have
especially when he's looking at it for
the first time
so those guys like what was the idea
behind having them slowly drop down in
was that like inspired from the book was
that a specific thing to knee wanted so
they've got gravity bills and they come
in slowly because they drop out of the
sky at full speed hitting the belt and
it slows them down so there you go in
that moment here they're trying to
surprise attacks that's all coming in
slow but also adds a lot of drama
seriously though like what a moment of
tension you're just like oh they're
floating yeah
that looked very practical it looked
like people were being dropped down on
wires was that the case and it was just
simply wire paint else were those
characters CG uh so some of those are CG
and some of those are real which ones
which I can't tell which ones they all
look real
you can see them in subtle moments where
um we've done some animation but they
bed in really well I mean hard surface
modeling is something that's relatively
easy these days to make look
photorealistic versus something that's a
little bit more organic and you're
having to deal with like light
scattering through a medium and stuff
like that the thing that holds it back
really comes down to the animation and
the animation here I think is pretty X
excellent because we had such good
mixture of some live action some CG we
could obviously balance it very well a
lot of times when you're floating down
do you want to be in a big heroic pose
people just don't sit there posing on
the way down so they need to look like
okay I'm holding my tension I'm
maneuvering myself in ready for battle
to get my sword up not like you know
coming down like Iron Man pose yeah I'm
very disappointed none of these guys
landed in a three-point pose it probably
is one somewhere he's in the back he's
in the very back
[Music]
it's adorable oh yeah it's so cute it
moves exactly like a real Mouse yeah it
skips and hops and little beats and
rhythms see the water going down there
the veins it's re-drinking the water
from its ear yeah dude tasty ear water
wasn't there like an actual real
physical puppet that someone built on
set for reference yeah so we had that
and they had it on set for lighting
reference and timing it kind of
developed from a few different creatures
really the initial images were of a
shortage of boa an elongated boa and it
was cobbled together and they have long
legs and they bounce like kangaroos
really now we started animating this in
shots it just looked a bit too cute
you know and it was just bouncing around
and it looked great but we just weren't
getting there but then he saw another
bit of footage then it was over kangaroo
rat which kind of similar but has
shorter Limbs and shorter legs and it's
much more kind of Ratty and bouncy so
then we have okay Remodel and change
proportions and then reanimate it and
then okay mouth so that's sort of like
that specific inspiration and adjustment
around that is what literally made this
click yes absolutely it was like the
light bulb moment so then we have this
kind of skipping kind of jumping yeah
scurrying like creature it's not happy
it's just like it's moving erratically
it's always on the lookout for someone's
gonna attack it also I love this super
quick small motions it's like not quite
on the order of like vibrating but it's
just like that sort of like quirky
quickness that you get from a small
culture micros micro adjustments yeah
that's the micro moves that's for the
detailers and we actually got some
controls to add noise functionality you
can key noise up and down and add a
little bits of vibration yes you're
moving and it's vibrating at the same
time yeah we did that quite a lot it
really helps we talk about the idea of
noise and visual effects and most people
think of noises you know like the
auditory aspect of noise but really it's
just random data that you can then plug
into channels like the movement of an
arm which you animate from here to there
but if you add the noise as well what
we're saying is like instead of here
there you goes
you know it's like it's an easy way to
naturally add variation the camera Shake
is a good example exactly yeah camera
Shake is essentially just like noise
added to the positional path everything
is moving at bodies next thing is still
because the fact that even when you're
still your heart's beating you're still
breathing so your body and chest shows
are always moving so that goes into
really deep VFX animation which might
not be present so much in future but
that adds that little kind of subtle
it's a noise is a is a big part of it so
speaking of tiny cute little animals uh
let's take a look at the human spider
which is only on screen for like a
moment but everybody's like oh what the
heck is this thing maybe we can shed a
little bit of light on this guy dude I
completely blocked this out of my memory
I don't remember it just terrifies
laughs
[Music]
it was crazy when it turned up it was
instantly one of the favorites for the
animation team they were like this is
repulsive and incredible at the same
time so the big question I always I had
was is this a human with sort of Limbs
attached to it like it's a spider or is
it a spider which has a human form and
this when you start thinking about it
it's disgusting you're like oh my God
this is horrific but really what it is
is an experiment so it's kind of like it
is a human because there's not actually
got legs that all arms oh right yeah
because they're all like they got
fingers at the end of each arm they've
got like tons of shoulder blades on the
back but then it has this kind of
bulbous end which is like a spider and
Denise found this reference of this
incredible ballerina and she does a
ballet performance like a spider so
obviously Dean being Dean Denise
contacted her and we've got her in a mo
capsule oh wow and she actually
performed on the day and it kind of
became the background reference of what
we're doing dang I didn't ever hear that
before yeah but the thing for this one
was all about posing how to get these
poses to read to have these fingers
working I had to feel comfortable but
awkward you know because again going
into this biology again this is not
lived as this creature's entire life and
bred for that purpose it's just been put
together so it's hard to walk it's a
tragic oh yeah hey are you enjoying this
episode so far do you want to see us go
even deeper into some of the really
Nitty Gritty details well we've done
that on our website quarterdigital.com
check it out you can get a free trial
thanks
God made that
Yes master
rise
so you did a stint at ilm for a few
years and one of the movies you worked
on was Star Wars Revenge of the Sith uh
what were some of the things that you
did for this movie I worked on a lot of
shots for these big Droid battles um a
bit of General Grievous and I got the
option to do a small bit of Yoda what a
statement yeah I did a little bit of
some Yoda
yeah I'm very lucky
for a character like General Grievous
right he's a very unique character he's
got extra appendages does the character
design kind of go hand in hand with the
animation or like does the character
design inform the animation or vice
versa it's a tricky balance you don't
want to use all of his things because
he's got them but it really is up to
what I guess the story point is do they
want to show him like here he's got two
arms out but why hasn't he got four
there he just didn't need to so I think
in those moments where you can have
those ideas you can try and Pitch them
so you know what it'd be great in this
moment that he pulls us two things out
at the same time on one side you
wouldn't expect it so we could do a lot
of other things really but his character
is effectively bipedal he's effectively
standing up like an actor however he can
move in all four so yeah because it's
like he's an Android you know he's
biological but he's mostly robot he's
kind of like Darth Vader it's kind of
tricky isn't it but I wasn't obviously I
am sleeping I was just an animator on
this show but if I was I would have
dived into that with the director to say
you know what is it which specific Yoda
shot did you do you remember working on
I think he was on the council
of General Grievous will end this war
I did as much of him just going hmm I
think that was it I don't think I think
it's one of these yeah I don't think he
even speaks yeah I'll be one of those
shots where like the moment you see it
like all the memories will just
instantly come flooding back like that's
the one yeah what kind of rules do you
have to obey when you're working with
Yoda just do exactly what they tell you
but interestingly enough on some of the
animation of Yoda they had this great
tool which I actually talked about with
doing the mouse it had this subtle noise
effect oh sure so when when Yoda's
moving his hands and putting his hands
on his Cane you can see it shaking so
they had this noise control that you
could add this kind of vibration okay
it's very hard to key that kind of
rotations but you can have this
procedurally in there and then you
keyframe on top of it twisted by the
dark side young Skywalker has become
boy you trained gone he is so Robin
you're you're an animation director
somebody's watching this they go wow
this is super cool this is a job I could
really get into where should they start
what should they do you do have to love
it I mean the most important thing is
Passion because it is a job which you
will get deep into and you'll want to go
deeper you're looking at the creatures
in spy and just trying to think about
say your favorite creature or even
animal and say oh how does that actually
work you've just got to study and
observe I do a lot of drawings and
Anatomy it's working out how muscles
will work and stuff and we don't have to
be a great artist you just gotta know
how to kind of communicate there's Great
Schools out there and lots of things to
learn but I think really it's
observation and passion definitely so
you know a really interesting motion to
study is that of a mouse pointer moving
over a button like a subscribe button
and clicking it try it out take a look
at the nuances see how it moves if you
can observe some like that noise and the
motion that we've been talking about
it'll be a really educational experience
give it a shot yeah it'd be really
important
[Music]
help us
you
can ask for comments we asked for
suggestions but I would actually like to
know what in your opinion is the coolest
thing that you've learned from watching
this show please let me know in the
comments down below it helps us know
what to focus on
what's up guys I hope you're enjoying
this react episode on this cozy Saturday
morning I'm here to talk to you about
today's sponsor Bessie so what are
embassies bessies are a very versatile
sustainably made sneaker they're
waterproof they have antibacterial souls
and they're vegan why I personally love
besties I use them for everything I work
out in them in the morning and I also
use them when I'm here at Corridor on
set I work out in them because they have
this antibacterial soul in there so it
keeps everything fresh so then when I
come to the studio in the same shoes no
one can tell that I worked out no stinky
feet here I use my besties while I'm set
because no matter what I'm dealing with
whether it's special effects props like
blood or oil I can just wash them right
off with a hose because they're 100
waterproof they're made from dymatex
which is a dual knit material that keep
your feet warm in the winter and cold in
the summer vestes are sustainably made
and vegan that means they're using less
material waste due to the knitting
process there's less water waste and
there's absolutely no animal byproducts
they come in a bunch of different colors
a bunch of different Styles so I'd say
hop over to the website bessie.com
quarter crew get 25 off each pair go
ahead and just grab a few so you have
multiple different options when you
click that link and you go to bestie.com
Corridor crew and you choose your pair
of Besties you want and you get 25 off
that pair of betsies I want you to
comment down below to let me know that
you said yesi to vesi
well that was incredible I learned a ton
I hope you learned a ton Robin it is a
privilege to have you join us on this
couch you have been a professional in
this industry for so many years you've
worked on so many incredible things
thank you for taking the time to share
it with us you're very welcome thanks
for having me it's been amazing to go
back down the history China Town see you
all about it but uh yeah it's always
changing and you guys are like the
future now right so thank you well I
can't wait to see June 2 hopefully
you're working on
no comment